LOT BETTER THAN WE'RE DOING NOW.
>> I LOVE YOU, BROTHER.
>> MAKE YOUR WITNESS.
>> THIS IS "DON LEMON TONIGHT."
AND WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT WHY
AMERICA IS SO ANGRY RIERKTS?
BECAUSE A LOT OF THE B.S. THAT'S
ALL THE MISINFORMATION THAT'S
SPREAD OUT THERE, THAT'S PART OF
IT.
YOU KNOW THE ANGER THAT SEEMS TO
BE ERUPTING EVERYWHERE FROM
PLANES TO SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS
AND BEYOND.
THE HATE SPEECH THAT TURNS INTO
VIOLENCE.
THE FEEDBACK LOOP THAT SEEMS TO
BE INFURIATING AMERICANS.
WELL, WHAT WE HEARD TODAY MAY
MAKE YOU REALLY ANGRY.
I WANT YOU TO LISTEN TO FACEBOOK
WHISTLEBLOWER FRANCES HAUGEN.
A 37-YEAR-OLD FORMER PRODUCT
MANAGER WHO TESTIFIED BEFORE
CONGRESS FOR MORE THAN THREE
HOURS SAYING THE COMPANY IS
PUTTING PROFITS BEFORE PEOPLE
AND PUTTING OUR DEMOCRACY AT
RISK.
>> I BELIEVE FACEBOOK'S PRODUCTS
HARM CHILDREN, STOKE DIVISION,
AND WEAKEN OUR DEMOCRACY.
THE COMPANY'S P LEADERSHIP KNOWS
HOW TO MAKE FACEBOOK AND
INSTAGRAM SAFER BUT WON'T MAKE
THE NECESSARY CHANGES BECAUSE
THEY HAVE PUT THEIR ASTRONOMICAL
PROFITS BEFORE PEOPLE.
CONGRESSIONAL ACTION IS NEEDED.
THEY WON'T SOLVE THIS CRISIS
WITHOUT YOUR HELP.
>> SO HERE'S WHAT SHE'S SAYING.
SHE'S SAYING THAT FACEBOOK'S
SYSTEMS ONLY CATCH A TINY
PERCENTAGE OF HATE SPEECH.
HATE SPEECH THAT IS SPREADING
ALL ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
>> THE REALITY IS THAT WE'VE
SEEN FROM REPEATED DOCUMENTS
WITHIN MY DISCLOSURES IS THAT
FACEBOOK'S A.I. SYSTEMS ONLY
CATCH A VERY TINY MINORITY OF
OFFENDING CONTENT AND BEST CASE
SCENARIO IN THE CASE OF
SOMETHING LIKE HATE SPEECH AT
MOST THEY'LL EVER GET 1200% TO
20%.
>> 10% TO 20%.
THINK ABOUT IT.
YOU THINK OH, 10% IS A LOT.
BUT THINK ABOUT HOW MUCH HATE
SPEECH IS GETTING PAST THEM WHEN
YOU CONSIDER THEY'VE GOTTEN
NEARLY 3 BILLION ACTIVE USERS.
AND WITH THIS COMPANY UNDER
SIEGE MARK ZUCKERBERG IS
ADDRESSING THE WHISTLEBLOWER'S
ALLEGATIONS IN A POST ON
FACEBOOK TONIGHT SAYING, AND I
QUOTE, "I'M SURE MANY OF YOU
HAVE FOUND THE RECENT COVERAGE
HARD TO READ BECAUSE IT JUST
DOESN'T REFLECT THE COMPANY WE
KNOW."
AND GOING ON TO SAY THAT "MANY
OF THE CLAIMS DON'T MAKE ANY
SENSE."
BUT YOU KNOW, TODAY'S HEARING,
THE OUTRAGE OVER FACEBOOK'S ROLE
IN THE SPREAD OF MISINFORMATION
IS JUST LIKE WHAT HAPPENED WITH
BIG TOBACCO.
I WAS JUST TELLING CHRIS THAT
EARLIER.
IN 1994 YOU MAY RECALL THE
EXECUTIVES OF THE BIG TOBACCO
COMPANIES STOOD UP IN FRONT OF
CONGRESS.
THEY SWORE TO TELL THE TRUTH,
DENIED THEIR PRODUCT WAS
ADDICTIVE, PUTTING THEIR PROFITS
AHEAD OF AMERICANS' HEALTH.
AND HERE WE ARE TONIGHT.
FACEBOOK HAVING ITS OWN BIG
TOBACCO MOMENT AS AMERICANS GET
ANGRIER.
ANOTHER SCHOOL BOARD MEETING,
ANOTHER SHOUTING MATCH OVER
VACCINES.
>> I'M SPEAKING THIS WAY
BECAUSE --
>> ORDER.
WE'RE ON A NEW TOPIC --
>> NO, WE'RE NOT!
WE ARE NOT!
>> YOU'RE BEING DISRUPTIVE.
YOU'RE BEING DISRUPTIVE.
>> SO LAST NIGHT --
>> WE'RE GOING TO ADJOURN, TAKE
A FIVE-MINUTE RECESS.
>> EXHIBIT A.
PARENTS YELLING AND SCREAMING
ABOUT VACCINES THAT COULD SAVE
THEIR CHILDREN'S LIVES AS MORE
THAN 700,000 AMERICANS HAVE DIED
IN THIS PANDEMIC.
AND LET'S NOT FORGET THE ANGER
THAT EXPLODED INTO ONE OF THE
DARKEST DAYS IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
BL
BLOODTHIRSTY RIOTERS ATTACKING
THE SEAT OF OUR DEMOCRACY ON
JANUARY 6th.
LET'S NOT FORGET THEY TRIED TO
OVERTURN A FREE AND FAIR
ELECTION.
AND LET'S NOT FORGET THE RIOTERS
PUT UP A GALLOWS OUTSIDE AND
CHANTED "HANG MIKE PENCE."
>> HANG MIKE PENCE!
HANG MIKE PENCE!
>> LET'S NOT FORGET THAT THEN
VICE PRESIDENT AND HIS FAMILY
HAD TO RUN FOR THEIR LIVES.
DON'T BELIEVE ME?
LOOK.
THERE'S THE VIDEO RIGHT THERE.
WE CAN NEVER FORGET WHAT WE SAW.
BUT APPARENTLY MIKE PENCE HAS
FORGOTTEN ALL ABOUT IT.
IMAGINE THAT.
I WANT YOU TO LISTEN TO HIM
RESORTING TO PAGE 1 IN THE TRUMP
PLAYBOOK, BLAME THE MEDIA.
REALLY HE'S TRYING TO BLAME THE
MEDIA.
TRYING TO BLAME THE MEDIA FOR
THE ATTACK BY VIOLENT RIOTERS.
TRUMP SUPPORTERS.
AN ATTACK THAT FORCED HIM TO RUN
FOR HIS LIFE WITH HIS FAMILY.
>> I KNOW THE MEDIA WANTS TO
DISTRACT FROM THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION'S FAILED AGENDA
BY FOCUSING ON ONE DAY IN
JANUARY.
THEY WANT TO USE THAT ONE DAY TO
TRY AND DEMEAN THE CHARACTER AND
INTENTIONS OF 74 MILLION
AMERICANS WHO BELIEVED WE COULD
BE STRONG AGAIN AND PROSPEROUS
AGAIN AND SUPPORTED OUR
ADMINISTRATION IN 2016 AND 2020.
>> GOOGLE STOCKHOLM SYNDROME.
TRYING TO GET ON THE GOOD SIDE
OF THE MAN WHO STOOD BY AND DID
NOTHING WHILE PENCE'S LIFE WAS
LITERALLY IN DANGER, ALL BECAUSE
HE DID HIS JOB INSTEAD OF TRYING
TO OVERTURN THE ELECTION AS HIS
BOSS WANTED HIM TO DO.
AND WHAT HAPPENED ON JANUARY
6th?
NOT JUST ABOUT ONE DAY.
IT'S ABOUT THE VERY REAL THREAT
TO OUR DEMOCRACY.
THE ANGER.
THE MISINFORMATION.
STILL OUT THERE.
THE BIG LIE OF NON-EXISTENT
ELECTION FRAUD STILL OUT THERE.
LAYING THE GROUNDWORK FOR THE
NEXT TIME.
BUT FAR TOO MANY REPUBLICANS ARE
PUTTING THEIR POLITICAL LIVES
AHEAD OF THE DEFENSE OF OUR
DEMOCRACY.
NIKKI HALEY.
OKAY?
NIKKI HALEY TELLING THE "WALL
STREET JOURNAL" THE FORMER
PRESIDENT IS A FRIEND AND SAYING
SHE'S CONSULT WITH HIM BEFORE
THROWING HER HAT INTO THE RING
FOR A WHITE HOUSE RUN.
UM.
I FEEL LIKE I KNOW HOW THAT
CONVERSATION WOULD GO.
AND I PROBABLY CAN'T REPEAT THE
EXACT WORDS THAT HE MIGHT USE.
REMEMBER WHEN SHE SAID THAT SHE
WAS DISGUSTED BY HIS TREATMENT
OF MIKE PENCE, DISGUSTED?
REMEMBER WHEN SHE SAID THAT SHE
DIDN'T THINK THE FORMER
PRESIDENT WAS GOING TO BE IN THE
PICTURE ANYMORE?
NOW SHE SAYS THEY NEED HIM IN
THE GOP.
THE LAST THING THEY NEED.
AND THEN THERE IS FORMER TRUMP
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
STEPHANIE GRISHAM.
YOU KNOW, THE ONE WHO NEVER HELD
A PRESS BRIEFING, WHICH WAS HER
JOB.
NOW SHE IS WARNING IF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT WERE TO WIN A SECOND
TERM HE WOULD SURROUND HIMSELF
WITH THE JANUARY 6th CROWD.
>> I HAVE SAID PEOPLE SUCH AS
SIDNEY POWELL OR RUDY GIULIANI
OR SOME OF THE PEOPLE WHO
BELIEVE WHOLEHEARTEDLY IN THESE
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, I BELIEVE
THAT IF HE WERE TO WIN IN 2024
HE WILL PICK WHOEVER STOOD BY
HIM, YOU KNOW, DEFENDED HIM, AND
HE WILL PLACE THOSE PEOPLE WHO
WILL HAVE DEFENDED THE
INDEFENSIBLE INTO THE WHITE
HOUSE.
>> OKAY.
THERE'S SO MUCH I WANT TO SAY.
WHERE WERE THESE PEOPLE WHEN IT
WAS HAPPENING?
WHEN THEY WERE -- JUST HOLD THE
PROMPTER.
WHERE WERE THESE PEOPLE?
WHEN THEY WERE -- WHERE WAS THIS
ATTITUDE WHEN THEY WERE ON FOX
NEWS SAYING THE MOST INSANE --
THE MOST INSANE STUFF, DEFENDING
THE MOST INSANE BEHAVIOR TALKING
CRAP ABOUT CNN AND THE FAKE
NEWS, NOT HOLDING PRESS
CONFERENCES, MAKING EXCUSES FOR
EVERYTHING THAT TRUMP DID,
PLAYING CLEANUP ON AISLE 45.
EVERY DAY.
NOW THEY WANT TO COME ON CNN.
WHY DO YOU WANT TO COME ON CNN
TO SELL A BOOK WHEN ALL YOU DID
WAS TALK CRAP ABOUT CNN?
HUH?
OR ANY OTHER NETWORK.
GO ON THE FOX PROPAGANDA NETWORK
AND SELL YOUR BOOK.
WHY DIDN'T YOU STAND UP FOR OUR
DEMOCRACY WHEN YOU HAD THE
CHANCE TO DO IT?
WHEN IT MATTERED.
BEFORE THERE WAS A JANUARY 6th.
BECAUSE YOU SAW IT COMING.
STEPHANIE GRISHAM, THE FACT IS
SHE SAW PLENTY WHEN SHE WAS IN
THE WHITE HOUSE HERSELF.
SHE COULD HAVE WARNED AMERICA
THEN.
SHE DIDN'T DO IT.
NOW SHE'S RUNNING TO JAKE
TAPPER, TALKING ABOUT THE THEN
PRESIDENT WAS TRYING TO STAGE A
COUP?
NO CRAP.
>> YOU THINK THE PRESIDENT WAS
ESSENTIALLY TRYING TO STAGE A
COUP?
>> I DO.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT HE WAS
DOING TO VICE PRESIDENT PENCE,
WHEN YOU LOOK AT HOW MANY WAYS
HE WAS TRYING TO GET PEOPLE, IN
PHONE CALLS EVEN WITH GEORGIA
AND ARIZONA AND THEN AGAIN WITH
PRESSURING MIKE PENCE WITH ALL
HE WANTED TO DO AND IN THAT MEMO
THAT HAS NOW COME OUT ABOUT ALL
THE WAYS TO OVERTURN THIS
ELECTION, I DO.
IT'S DANGEROUS.